[موسيقى]
كنا الأشخاص الوحيدين في الإمارات العربية المتحدة الذين
بدأوا شيخوخة جافة لأفراد لحوم
البقر هنا فقط لتناول
جودة اللحوم التي يقدمونها ، وأعني أن
الكتابة عملية شاقة للغاية ولا
يستطيع الجميع فعلها بكلمة شيخوخة جافة
هل تقوم بتجفيف اللحم خارجًا ، لذا فإن
سحب كل الرطوبة وإعطائه تلك
النكهة الشديدة ، لدينا منشأة
يتم غلقها بالقفل والمفتاح
هناك رطوبة يجب
الحفاظ عليها عند درجة حرارة
معينة يجب الحفاظ عليها ، لذلك ضع  كل
هذه العوامل معًا لدينا
مرفق ولا يُسمح إلا بشخص واحد
في
[الموسيقى]
لذلك نساعد اللحم البقري لمدة 40 يومًا
كحد أدنى
نقوم بتنظيفه
ثم نعيد العبوة ونتركه يرتاح ونطبخه
حسب الرغبة.  خمن كيف يعجبهم ،
نحن لا نستخدم أي إضافات ، ولا مواد
حافظة ، ولا ملح ، لا شيء ، ليس هناك
سوى لحم البقر ، وخصر الشريط الذي قمنا
بتجفيفه في Jack Daniels ، لذلك
هذا هو الشيء الوحيد الذي نضيفه
لإعطاء تلك النكهة
لذلك نحن مسعرين  في 295 إلى 270
لذلك  295 نحاول أن تعرف
قطعة لحم بقر تمت تربيتها
في المنزل ومعالجتها ، أعتقد أنها
صفقة رائعة
[موسيقى]
أنت